is there any regret in your mind about
about how it played out
um you got to the championship game and
your first round pick didn't play a snap
and you know maybe if you did something
different
maybe you'd have gotten over the hump no
um don't look at it that way
um really no regrets looking back at the
draft last year i think obviously the
the opportunities that our players got
from that draft class i thought they
performed very well i think there were
you know limited opportunities and
obviously we had some unfortunate
injuries
uh we had some covid situations we went
through as well but
looking at all those guys that we
drafted last year i'm excited about
their future and what they can do for
the green bay packers
and the opportunities they were given i
thought they performed well
you got to ask the question but there's
no way that brian good acoustic is going
to come out and say yeah you know what
we really screwed up by
trading up in round one to get a
quarterback who
did nothing in 2020 as a rookie and if
only we had spent the first round pick
and the fourth round pick that was
packaged to move up we would have had a
couple of players who could have made a
difference against the tampa bay
buccaneers that's unprovable without a
time machine or an alternate reality
chris but
at some level surely brian guticus in a
quiet moment
has thought once or twice or more often
this year
man maybe i just should have gone out
and got some players who could have
helped us make a difference in that nfc
championship
uh against the buccaneers i mean
i would hope so but they're not going to
admit it now of course because that's
too obvious and everybody's been
throwing it into their face and all of
those
issues but you know really when you look
at it as a whole
okay mike what was what's what's the
difference between the
the team that lost to the 49ers in the
nfc championship game and the team we
just saw this past year
i mean it was the same team there was
nothing different about it
they did nothing free agency draft
nothing no
it's just the players went back and
worked harder we just we'll work harder
don't help us out it's all right oh
don't worry that the two teams in the
super bowl got draft picks that
oh get wait for it i'll contribute a lot
that's right the whole year
and are big players in this game right
now so
you can't swipe that under the rug no
matter how
easily you know or how you know quietly
they try yeah i don't know if that made
sense there
but either way we're all going to have
our eye on these draft picks for years
to come i mean this is they're going to
be evaluated for the next four or five
years
i think that's the first time that
you've created like a bookend to a
simsism because you're being
you've been saying sweep it under the
radar and now you get an opportunity to
say sweep it under the right thing but
you swipe it under the rug
so swipe it under the right mean two
swipe it under the rug
you no you never do you never do that's
what makes it
that's what makes it so much fun i had
derek brooks tell me last night
quit going quick being so hard on my guy
chris sims i said he makes it too easy
to be hard on him so at least he got
brooks in your corner
um yes hey
packers you're right they didn't do
anything we saw in 2019 that's when they
went out
and made some moves and made aaron
rodgers happy and brought in some
veteran free agents
and they're going to have the chance to
do it this year
the salary cap is most likely going to
go down
clark hunt the chief's owner who's the
chairman of the finance committee
said yesterday that they may not even
know what the final
salary cap number is until hours before
the start of the league year this is
going to be a tough negotiation
among teams and then between the nfl and
the union
there could be a bunch of free agents
out there good
quality players that the packers if they
manage the cap right can go out
and grab to try to get over the hump
we'll see if they do it
they're clearly going to have aaron
rodgers though he's not retiring
he's not leaving they're not trading and
we know all of that but there's still
that lack of long-term clarity that
aaron rodgers may want here's goodie
clothes yesterday talking about his
franchise quarterback who soon will be
named the 2020 mvp
obviously he's got you know he's under
crowd checked he's playing at an
extremely high level
what we're trying to do as an
organization and what we're trying to
accomplish here we can't do without
aaron rodgers right now
so he he's such a part of of what we've
done
he's such a part of what we're doing
right now and and certainly in the
future
he's under contract that that's the
subtle
way of saying you ain't getting a new
contract potentially i mean because
the new contract gives the commitment
that gives the clarity that aaron
rodgers
should want i i don't want to speak for
it maybe he doesn't like that oh maybe
he doesn't like that no i think he but
but then why would he say
his future's uncertain there are a lot
of uncertain futures here myself
included again
that's the fuse that was lit we don't
know where that fuse is going
it's i know
no no it's not more money it's it's
commitment
it's commitment it is let i
i suspect and again he doesn't want
people reading his mind or interpreting
the messages he's sending to goody kunst
and mark murphy the ceo of the team if
i'm aaron rodgers
i want to know what's the deal with
jordan love
is he going to be traded like jimmy
garoppolo was after a few years
or is he going to be the guy who i was
when you decide you've had enough of the
starter and it's time to put the first
round pick
on the field i mean how rogers fell into
their laps
they traded up to get jordan love there
was something about jordan love
that they had to have they went to get
him so
that's the claret that's i believe the
core
of what aaron rodgers wants to know he
put together an mvp season he did
everything he
could do to help that team get to a
super bowl and win it with no help
around him not no help
limited help around him no effort by the
packers to make the team better like you
said
i want to know am i on a year to year
arrangement here if i have a bad year in
2021 am i
gone for 2022 are you just waiting for
me to slip up
so you can go with jordan love what's
really going on here give me that
clarity
i don't think they want to give it to
him because i think they like having a
pissed off sorry london
aaron rodgers who's going to show up
next year and have another mvp season if
he doesn't have that clarity
yeah well that's a possibility and i
don't know did i
you got me there okay good i glitched
for a second i mean that's a possibility
and
for for aaron rodgers i mean
i'm okay if they don't want to help the
team out or do anything like that maybe
you just go all right kiss my butt i'm
out of here in two years no matter what
because you're right all the warning
signs say
they want to play jordan love at some
point in the next four or five years
right the next three or four years
now are they going to really go all in
for rogers and put a team around them to
now where they become really good for
the next three or four years
maybe five and now jordan love becomes a
mute point
you know going forward i don't know
that's going to be the the risk reward
of that factor oh support rogers
whoa the jordan love things gonna have
to wait probably longer
don't support rogers now all the
pressure's on rogers to make it all
happen
and maybe we could see that year he
falters that's when they try to
you know put a jordan love in there now
that that's it's going to be on
guten coast and the front office to
really
help steer that discussion to a degree
and that's where i'm going to be
interested
too will they go all in on rogers mike
here's the big thing because you know
you hear about it so much rogers choking
playoffs all those things
players matter everybody players really
matter and they really matter
and play off football it's no mistake
that the two
freakiest teams in football are in the
super bowl
with just freaks all over the field on
both sides of the ball
you know aaron rodgers and the green bay
packers they're so
built through him mike and his ability
to execute and make throws
but what happens in the playoffs mike
they don't call past interference you're
allowed to hold and do things
it's hard to just execute the defenses
are
better so now you need some guys that
can just go
i can beat that guy i'm tyree kill you
can't hold me because i'm too fast
or if you miss i'm gonna run by you for
an 80 yard touchdown
oh and now the db goes let me play off i
won't even try to do that
there's none of that with the packers
across the board any of it
hold them every play doesn't matter i'm
not scared of anybody on their team
and that's why you sit there and go i
need
players you need big time defensive
tackles and people like that to help
winning those type of games because
we didn't see flags and executing's not
just going to get it done it's about
hitting
and tackling and making plays and that's
what the two teams in the super bowl do
and the packers don't they just rely on
one guy
to put pressure on the other team
through his great throws and execution
and it's just almost impossible to win
like that three games to win a super
bowl
could you imagine what aaron rodgers
would do with tyree kill and travis
kelsey not to take anything
away from patrick mahomes we love
patrick mahomes
but could you imagine what aaron rodgers
would do with weapons like that
and surely i mean he's smart enough to
reflect while he's having scotch or
tequila whatever his mood may be that
evening
on now he loves devonta adams but to
have
those weapons and then michael hardman
and sami watkins on those rare occasions
when he's healthy i mean my goodness
what a difference that would be for
aaron rodgers we'll see if they give him
what he's looking for one other quick
thing about
goody koon's press conference yesterday
he came out and said there was no truth
to the report from sam farmer the la
times that the rams made a run at aaron
rodgers and goody koons did not hesitate
now
sam farmer does not have a reputation
for being wrong it's not like he's out
there trying to get
clicks or or attention by by
you know taking things that weren't
accurate and trying to craft them into a
story
so i don't know what happened there i
don't know if it was just mcveigh
calling up leflore since their former
colleagues before saying don't even
bother
and it not getting back to good accounts
but goody koontz was was willing to say
no truth to that
to that rumor and i i think the last
thing goody coons wants is a bunch of
teams calling up making offers for aaron
rodgers because that gives rogers
leverage if it happens yeah that gives
him power if he's in demand
if half the teams in the league are
saying we want him we want him we want
him
that allows him to say will you just
please give me the clarity that i'm
looking for
am i going to be here or am i not no i
know that's where that's where
in some ways i i wonder if aaron rodgers
wants that
contract security or clarity maybe he's
just going what
they're going to give me contract
clarity okay security
and still not add to the football team
and i'm gonna be stuck in this same oh
aaron rodgers can't win the nfc
championship game conversation
maybe he's had enough of that crap too
maybe he's willing to go
let's just see how the next year or two
go and i'll see where it goes and maybe
i'll just keep my current contract and
i'll play hardball when it comes time to
you take a page from the tom brady
playbook you finish off your contract
and then you go to that year's
equivalent
of the tampa bay buccaneers exactly
that's how it
plays out hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports